では よろしくお願いします
はい 今日は集中力について話してみます
えーと まあ自由にならない集中力の不思議ということ
で 幸福のための精神統一
あの なんて言ったら読めない
鍛錬後 えーと まあ集中力はまあ良いことですと
まあこちらにちょっと見えません
後ろ見えますかね 大体ね
宗教と関係なく 集中力でいえば
まあ宗教に興味ない人々でもね
大変いいことだとは言ってますね
まあ英語に英語でやっても
コンセントレーションというね
コンセントレーション
決して悪いことじゃないということは
まあ世間一般的にみんな知ってるんです
集中力は良いものだという考えが固定してますね
人間の経験から成り立っている考えなので
まあ違うとは言えないんですね
例えば心理学の研究者たちやらね
まあ集中力はいいものだと言っているのは
いろいろ調べて研究しておっしゃってるでしょうに
学問の場合でも スポーツの場合でも
研究の場合でも どんなところでも
やっぱり集中力っていうものはとても必要だとは思っているし
まあそれなりのデータがあって言っていると思います
確かに仕事 勉強 訓練などで集中力があれば効率は高いし
能力も向上するんです
まあそういうまあ証拠もありますね
しかし 問題はこの必要不可欠な集中力には自由にならないことです
そんなに大事なことだったら
みんなあればいいでしょうに
能力は向上するわ まあ効率は上がるわ
まあすぐ何でもできるようになるんだというね
大変いいことなのに 勉強する時でも集中力があれば勉強はうまくいくわ
勉強したものはもう覚えてしまうというね
まあいいことばっかりなんですけど
そんなにいいことならね
まあスポーツの場合でもね
スポーツをする時でも
やっぱり集中力が必要なんですよ
集中力があればうまくいくんで
いくらプロであっても集中力がなくなっちゃうともうダメになっちゃうんですね
なのにこれ なかなか自由にはならないんですね
良いものなんですけど
なかなか手に入らないという
いうこともまたかえって事実なんです
では なんで自由にならないということについて考えておきましょう
集中力は良いものだと信じているだけで
集中力があれば物事はスムーズに進むことも知っているだけで
集中力とは心理的にどのようなものか
育てられるものか 先天的なものかなどは調べたことはないんです
心理学の本とか読んでみてください
いかに集中力を育てるのかという
全然ないんです あらゆる研究していますよ
この病気はどうなったんですか？あの病気はどうなったんですか？この現象はこの病名でもう研究しましょうとかはあるんだけど
いかに集中力というものを育てるのか
集中力って心理学的にどんな現象なのかと
全然研究していないんです
面白いんですよ こんなに必要なものはなんで研究しないんですかね
例えばもう対人なんとかとか
病気とかね もう競争恐怖症とかね
そういう心理的なものをみちょこちみちょこち分析するんですけど
だからまあそれよりも普通の人間にもね
より立派な人間になれるように
心理学の世界で研究する方々はね
集中力について研究して
もっと現代的なね 機械やらいろんなものを作れます
もう使えますからね 我々にはそんなのもアクセスも何もできませんし
脳波はもう測ってみるわ
もうモニター画面で出したりとか
もうあらゆることやっているのに
集中力って何なのかとなかなか誰も研究しないんですね
面白いんですね そんなに大事なことなのに
内容を理解できれば集中力は育てます
だからまあ残念ですけど
これから仏教の世界から話さなくちゃいけないんですね
だから集中力ってどういうものかと内容を理解しておけば
まあ育てられます 育てることができれば
まあ自由になります 自分の手に入れます
自分のものになります
集中力について詳細に学ぶということで
これから学んでみましょう
集中力とは 心に入った対象から離れ
離れることなく対象にすぎていることです
集中力っていうのは もう心に入ったものから離れないんですね
それと一緒にべったしずついてるんです
その状況なんです 反対に
心は好き勝手に様々な対象に情報に振り回されることは集中力がないということなんです
例えば 本を読む例で考えてみると
本は読んでいるんですけど
もういろんな耳に入る音にも音が気になったり
人が隣で喋っていることを聞いてしまったり
それについて考えたりしたり
また本も読んでいると集中力って全くないんですね
まあ集中力というのは
自分が本を読んでいて
隣で誰か二人が喋ってるんですけど
何喋ってるかさっぱりわからなかったというならば
あんた聞いてるの？全然聞いてないんだよと
あんた何言ったのかと
後で言うぐらいだったら
もう集中力があって 本を読んだことになるんですね
だから 集中力の定義はまず理解しておきましょう
自分やることから 自分の心の対象ですね
しっかりとした定義は
この対象についているんですね
釘付けているんですね
離れないんです それが集中力なんですね
風に揺れる旗のように
心に安定感がないならば
集中力がないんですね
もうこの旗の例は一応仏典に出ているんだからね
集中力がないことが仏教では情動というんですけど
心は興奮 混乱している状態
揺れるんですね 激しく心が揺れているならば
集中力は全くないんだと
だから揺れる心からは何もできません
だから 揺れ動く心で本を読んでも
読んだり 別なことを考えたり
全く関係ないことに心行ったり
また読んだり また人が言うことを気になったり
それにもまた答えたりしたり
頭なんか戦争状態なんですね
それでは頭は成長することもないし
読んだ内容が理解できるわけでも
覚えてしまうこともなくなっちゃうんですね
だから集中力がないことっていうのは
すごい心が弱い です 集中力がある時
心は基層に立てられた柱のようです
しっかりした基層に立てられた柱というものは
揺れると困るでしょう
家なんか作る場合はね
柱だけでもしっかりと頑丈で揺れ動くしないでいてほしいんですね
ですから このしっかりとこの対象につけて
揺れない 動かない状態が集中力なんですね
それぐらい定義でわかれば
もう簡単に集中力を育てられると思いますよ
まあそれから集中力についていくらか分析してみます
先天的にある集中力 聞いたことがないでしょう
脳細胞が発達していない生命体は
遺伝 遺伝的にプログラムされていないものを知ることさえもしないんです
ちょっとややこしい文章ですけど
動物は自分に関係ないものはもう知り得ないんです
でね もうアヒルとかね
生まれてすぐ動くものを見たら
それ親だと思っちゃうしね
で それから実際自分の親は見てももうわからないんですね
最初に決めた 最初に目に入ったものは親ですから
まあ例えば猫なんかはね
ものを動くんだったらすぐ興味が持つんですね
動かないでいると 猫に見えているかどうかさっぱりわからないんですね
動かないものは それでよくよく猫なんか観察してみると
もう藪に入ったりして
いろんな動く鳥とかね
狙っているんですね その時
すごい集中力なんです
その狙っているものにじっと見て
目がもうどこにも行かないんです
それで体しっかり変わるんですよ
獲物を狙っていると 体しっかり変わって
動き方やら尾っぽの振り方が全部もう一つに徹底的に集中するんです
その時に限って 私は時々見られる時は猫にしゃべるんですね
聞こえないんです もうかなり集中力
それでそれでもいろいろ喋ったりなんとかすると
もう集中力切れちゃうでしょ
すぐ忘れてるんで もう今獲物を狙って狙っていたんですけど
それはできなくなったっていうか
もう忘れてるんです 集中力を切れたったんです
だから今まで何やっていたのかとかね
もう動物殺すんじゃないよとか
私は説教するんですけど
猫は何のことかと そんなことやったのかっていう顔をするんですね
ですから このそういう動物たち
何かやる場合はね しっかり集中力でやっているんです
それは先天的なんですね
他のことを理解させようと思っても無理です
ただ ミミズはミミズの世界で生きているのであって
アリはアリの世界でね
例えば食べ物があったら
どこであっても アリたちがザーッとそちらへ行くでしょうね
それから殺虫剤かけられて死ぬかもしれない
そんなことを考える理由がないんです
あのカラスみたいに周りも見て
パッと取って逃げようという
そういうふうな思考ないんです
食べ物があったらそちらに行く
で ネズミになってくると違いますね
食べ物があったら狙いたいんですけど
周りをよく見て 人間でもいるのかどうかね
見て餌のところに行くんですね
だから それぞれ動物たちにはそういう集中力があったりなかったりなんです
だから餌をまいてアリを捕まりたければ
いとも簡単です ネズミは捕まりませんね
アリは迷子にならない
ミツバチは花が咲いているとところに飛んで
自分の巣にちゃんと帰ります
だから私たちはね ミツバチの巣がどこにあるか
そういうの難しいんで
探すのは 同じ木たくさんなりまってね
そこで野生の場合はね
あるいは養殖している場合でも
同じそうでしょ 形も同じで
看板書いてないし 番号振ってないし
あなた方ミツバチたちはB3だよとかね
あなた方ミツバチたちはB5だよとかないんですよ
ただたくさん箱を並べて買ってるだけで
それぞれちゃんと自分の箱に行くんです
迷子になることはないんです
だからアリとかね まあ皆様あんまり目に入りませんだからね
私たちは 私はかなり動物を野生のね
まあよく見るのは好きですけどね
俺はまあ人間見ると気持ち悪くなるんだからね
アリを見ていると全然そんなことはないんです
で 結構距離は行くんですよ
よくも迷子にならないんですね
それで私がわざと迷子にさせるんです
見ていて まあ並んでいくんだからね
匂いかなんとか嗅いで道を作ってますからね
それで私は歩いて まだ道の間でずっと指で削ったりしてね
拭いたりすると その間でこの匂いがなくなってるんですね
そこでカチッと止めて待ってるんですね
動かなくなっちゃって
それで群がっちゃうんで
そこでやっぱり勇気のあるアリ一匹ぐらいは
なんとなくどうでもいいんだからと先に進んだんですね
進んだら そこからまたあれたちが行くんですね
だから ちゃんと自分が決めた目的に行く
決めたことから脱線しない
揺れ動きはない それが集中力だと定義しましたから
なんかアリにもあるんですね
見てみれば 人間の中でも頭がそれほど優れていない人々は決まったパターンで生きているでしょうに
あの知識的にいろいろね
あまり優れていない方々についてはね
皆様経験があると思いますけど
あるいくつかはできます
それもしっかりするんです
私たちならもう面白くないとか飽きちゃいますけど
そういう方々は自分に決まった仕事をしっかりしてくれるんです
だから この知識的にね
いろいろトラブルある方々にとっても
ちゃんと仕事はあるんですよ
いろんな何かを組み立てるとかね
で 何か教えてあげれば
例えば箱にシールを貼るとかね
教えてあげれば それはしっかりと何のこともなくやっているんです
しかし この箱の中身も調べて
売り物になるかならないかと品質も管理してから OK シール貼ってくださいと言っちゃうと
これできないんです だから誰かが品物を調べて
もう品質は OK だったら流してあげれば
その人はそちらに OK シール出して
別なベルトで来るものにはバツシールを貼って貼ってくれたりはします
だから結構可愛いといえば可愛いんですよ
もうもうよくわかりやすいし
で こういうことを言ったらこの人怒るだろうとかね
こういうことを知っちゃうと混乱するだろうとか
それははっきりしていて
で 管理もしやすいし もうその集中力があるところでうまく使用すれば
本人にも収入があって
我々普通の社会にも負担ではないんですね
だからこの余計なことを考えられない
だから考えてないんです
だからその対象にしっかりしているんです
これも集中力ですよ 別なことに誘惑することは難しい
そういう人々 例えばワンパターンの仕事をずっとしていて
誰か横から話しかけてなんとかやりましょうと言ってもわからないんです
し 出てこないんです 誘惑することは難しいんです
はい そういうことで この先天的な集中力なんですね
先天的な集中力は 単純に生命を維持するためにための基本的な力です
誰にでもあるんです これ
ない人はいないんです
ない生命はいないんです
この先天的な集中力  それはどういうことかって
やっぱりあの猫がね 動くものにしっかりと集中しないと
どうやって獲物を取るんですかね
だからまあ生きていられなくなるんです
人間にも先天的ないろいろ集中力はついています
それがなんで先天的についているのかというと
生きるために必要なんです
生き続くために 死を避けるために
でないと もうみんな早くも死んでしまっちゃいます
だから まあ人間で ものすごく混乱している頭がどうにもならん
興奮状態でいる イカれてる人でも道路を歩くと気をつけてるでしょうに
それでもあんまりにも興奮して
右も左もわからなくなっちゃうと車にぶつかったりもする
しかし それってあまりにもひどい状態で
普通なら車にはぶつからないんです
それぐらいの集中力は人間にはあるんです
ということで どんな生命にも先天的にある程度で集中力があります
これでやっと死なないで生きているんです
あるパターンから離れることはできないという集中力なので
能力としてとして見れるが
物として見ることもできるんです
だからもう文章がややこしいんですから
また簡単に言います  集中力っていうのはありがたいことであると最初に言ったでしょうね
あれはなんとすごいことかという場合は能力なんですね
宝物なんですね しかし
この先天的な集中力考えてみると
あれは能力か能力ないかどちらにしますかと
例えば知識認知 認知的な問題ある方々も
それなりの施設などで仕事をしていますよ
しかし 大胆な仕事はできないんですね
大胆な仕事はできないんですね
認知過程でちょっとトラブルがある方々は
それって能力というべきか
能力がないというべきかというね
見方によって変わってしまいます
時々我々平気でね あの人にはそんなすごいことをできないんだから
まあこういう仕事を頼みましょうと
いうことになるんですね
しかし それも本当は先天的な集中力には変わりはありません
そこで私たちは 皆様 この先天的な集中力っていうことはね
例えばもう日本で長く生きてて
人生経験あるでしょう
じゃあ突然外国に行ったらどうします？何もできなくなるんです
じゃあ フランスにでも行って
レストランに行って じゃあ注文してみてください
何か食べ物でも まあ混乱しちゃって訳がわからなくなっちゃってね
フランスいろいろ名前聞いたことがありますけど
カタカナで書いてないんだからね
毒だと思っちゃうしね
だってフランスの文字っていうのはね
もう書いてるものじゃないんだから
読む場合は 我々普通のローマ字は読めますけど
あの人々は書くことじゃない
発音は別なもの発音するんです
ドイツ語の食べ物 名前なんか聞いただけで発音ができますけどね
食べ物じゃない感じしますよ
なんかすごい厳しい単語ですからね
あれ これって食べる食べるのでしょうかと
だからもう私たち慣れてないんですね
でも皆様には焼肉とかね
しゃぶしゃぶとかね 言うともういとも簡単にもう食べる
食べる前にもう美味しく味も感じているんです
そういうことで 私たちにはこの先天的な集中力があって
場所が変わるとちょっと対応できなくなってしまいますね
その時は失ってしまいますね
先天的な集中力は ですから
この動物園なんかはね
まあ最近あまり動物がいないんだからね
まあぜいたくにあれやってますけど
動物園でね 檻の中でいる虎は
ライオンはね 大変厳しいんですよ
自分の環境の中でいると落ち着いてちゃんと仕事できるんです
だからなんとなくそういう自然環境を作ろうとね
動物園は頑張ってますけど
あまり意味がないと思いますよ
まあそれだったらね もう獲物を生きたまんまで出さないと
虎が狙ってももう取って食べるようにとかね
とにかくぶつ切りにした肉そのまま捨てちゃいますから
やっぱり不自然は不自然なんですね
虎にとっては あの上野動物園の猿のために山を作ってます
山みたいなものをコンクリートでね
見る限り不自然で 猿たちはものすごいストレス溜まってると思います
そんなもんじゃないんだからね
森の中っていうのは だから森の中で落ち着いているんだから
集中力あるんだから 本当に自分の生きている力を発揮するんですよ
鳥たちもね 力いっぱい歌ったりするし
動物たちも力いっぱいもう鳴いたり叫んだり
いろいろ楽しく生活しているんです
だから 自分の命を支えてくれる環境で集中力っていうのは出てきます
で 社会に入ったら無口な人でも
家に入ったところでもよく喋りますからね
で また社会に入ったらまた何も喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
環境変わって そういうことだから
それ能力ですかね？あるいは能力ないことですかね
家でペラペラペラペラ喋るわ
喧嘩するわ 理屈つけてくるわとかね
そういう人は社会に入って
会社に学校でどこか行ったところで黙っているならば
これが能力か もう能力ないか
どちらにするかっていうね
まあ一応能力ないっていうことにしなくちゃいけないんですね
しかし 私が言いたいのは
それも集中 先天的な集中力ですよと
その問題はその環境からずれると機能しないんですね
では 私たちは陸上ではかなり体力があって
走ったり何でもできそうでしょうし
だから体力はあることは確かにありますけど
水に入ってみたらもう魚に負けますね
あの小さな魚でも攻撃してくるとどうすることもできなくなっちゃうんです
大変危険なんです だから体力でもその環境が変わると機能しない
サメが偉そうなことをするんだけど
人間を脅したりも何でも食ったり
サメを陸から上がってみれば何もできません
いくら鋭い歯があったってもね
もう噛もうともしないんです
ただ自分が暴れるだけで
じゃあ水の中でどうなるのかというと
もう大変な危険なんですね
だからそれ 体力の集中力じゃないんです
だから体力は生き延びるためにあります
しかし それはどんな環境で使うのかということも先天的に決まっている
集中力もそのその環境で機能するんですね
環境から離れたらもう働かないというものになっているんです
人間の場合はマインドコントロール
暗示をかけるなどに使用されるんですよ
その我々のこの先天的な集中力を世界でかなり悪用されています
だからそこは誰でも人間だから知ってます
人間が何に夢中になるのかと
例えば人間というのはもうもう言葉にすごく酔うんです
まあ本当に危ないんですけど
で 言葉に酔うんだから
意味がどうでもいいんです
理屈はもうまるっきり崩れてやったっても
気にもしない すごい迫力があって
もうかなり耳障りが良い言葉で
ものすごく喋りっぱなし
喋りだすとみんなもう圧倒されちゃって
暗示かけられちゃって
マインドコントロールされるんです
私は時々そういう あのまあ宗教っていろいろ組織なんかに行ってみたんですけど
このキリスト教関係のね
まあ新興宗教組織たくさんありますから
なんか舞台で泣き叫ぶは叫ぶは叫ぶは
神様よ 父親よ この人を助けてくださいと
ほら 見て まあ神様 あなたのことを見て
ものすごく力強く言うのに
みんな感動して バカどもたちが涙ポロポロで
単なるあのバカにマインドコントロールされているだけなんですけど
今 皆様は自分の体で神の存在を感じているではないですか
とかね いきなりそう感じてるでしょ？感じてるでしょ？と言ったら
いいえ 違いますよと言える
言えないんですよ なんて情けない人間かと
だから ちょっとでもうなずいたら
すぐ舞台に上がってもらって
この方に神の恵みは今もう降りかかっているんだぞとかね
これからあとは大変幸福なものだよとかね
あれやこれやと言って人を馬鹿にするんです
だから特にあの仏教は宗教だとしたくないんですから
宗教はみんなそうやってマインドコントロール
暗示かけて 人間は人間でなくなるようにするんですね
それが我々のこの先天的な
あるこの能力を悪用しているんです
だからまあ犬にもできますからね
いろんなことを教えちゃうと
もうそこに慣れてしまいますね
もうカラスでも飼ってみてください
何のことなく人間と同じく生活し始まるんです
喋ったりもするんです
いろいろ鳥飼うんだけど
カラスの方が一番ものすごく可愛いと思いますよ
で すっごく頭が良くて
よく喋ったりして そこで他の鳥たちは同じことを繰り返すんですけど
カラスも同じなんですけど
なんとなくもうあの反応するんですよ
対応するんですよ わかっているかどうか分かりませんだけど
よく対応までするのです
楽しいです それになってくると
で 決して病気にならないんだから飼いやすいんです
はい まあカラスを飼いなさいという場合じゃないんだから
笑 だからこのカラスでも鳥でも飼ってあげて
毎日同じことを言うと
まあそこを慣れて ちゃんとその人を見るとその言葉をかけるとかね
あるお寺で ある住職さんがこのなんかインコとか何とかいう鳥を飼っていたんです
住職さんがいつでもその鳥といろいろ遊んでいるんですね
喋ったりして そこでこのまあ
若い弟子も二人がいて
この長老は弟子たちにもなんとかこのいろいろ愛称を作ったりして
このからかっているんですね
いつでも だから長老が自分
自分の弟子のことはもうすごい好きで
いろいろからかったり使ったりするんで
その言ってる言葉がこの若者は嫌なんですね
長老に言われると何とも言えませんだけど
他の人を言うと なんかすごい失礼になるんです
この長老何やってるのかというと
あの二人がいたの 二人がない時はね
この二人に自分が言ってる
このからかってるために使ってる単語を教えてあげたりして
それでこの鳥もちゃんと呼んでくる時
すごいこの失礼な言葉でなんか馬鹿にしているんですね
それで子供があまりいい気分じゃないでしょうね
もう鳥に馬鹿にされると
その顔を見て長老が一人で勝手に喜んでいるんです
だからまあ そのオウムにしたっても
ちゃんと区分けして この人が来るとこの言葉
この人が来るとこの言葉やと
もうマインドコントロールされているんですね
そういうのは集中力がないとできないんです
暗示っていうのはすごい強引なことでしょ
暗示かける時でも この先天的な集中力が必要になるんです
だから結構暗示にかけられてしまう人々の方が多いんです
他人に自分の心を管理できる状態になるので
明らかに危険です だから先天的な集中力やといっても
ありがたがったらちょっと危ないんです
気をつけた方がいいんです
その先天的な集中力 みんなにあるんだから
どこでマインドコントロールされてしまうか
誰に暗示かけられてしまうか
誰に管理されてしまうか
わかったものじゃないんです
よくよく調べてください
自分の人生 あらゆるところで管理されていて
マインドコントロールされていて
いろいろ暗示かけられちゃって生きてるんですよ
大変です ないというのは
ただ気づいてないだけ
だからちゃんと勉強した方がいいんです
この先天的な集中力は何なのか
それは生きるためには必要ですが
悪用されないように 自分が誰かの奴隷にならないように
どうすればよろしいかということはこれから学ばなくちゃいけないんです
だから人間が喋ることは理解しますよ
そういう集中力はあります
が それでどうなるのかと
口が達者な人に会うと
もう大変ですよ だからまあ
大きな事件で言っても
いろいろこの詐欺事件にね
もうやられちゃうでしょうに
で なんかなんとか組織があって
もう 3ヶ月間でもう 5,000万儲かるぞとかなんとか言って
それでしゃべるは ビデオを作って放送したりして
すごい大胆な言葉で この会社の社長がしゃべったりで
みんな来る おばあさん
おじいさんたちが自分持ってるお金を全部出したりするんですね
それで 3ヶ月とかで 3円
3,000円儲かるところが
もう 3ヶ月間なってくると
あの場所は別なというか
他の人を借りてるんですね
調べに行ったら別な会社になっていてと
もう遅いんですよ それから警察に訴えたっても
自分の亡くなったお金が返ってこないんです
だから人間っていうのは
金儲けをと思っちゃうと
すぐ集中力が生まれてくるんです
それ使ってるんです 最近痩せるということでね
これなら痩せますよと言った途端
もうそれには集中力があるんです
痩せるためには何食べればいいかというね
減量です 痩せたければ食べなきゃ食べない方がいいでしょうに
飢えた方が痩せますけど
それで減量するで 痩せるために何を食べればいいかと考えるんです
それでダイエット食品の方が今 50%以上なんです
で その中でも皆様が何買うのかというと
内容ではなくて この暗示が誰が上手にかけるのかっていうことなんです
マインドコントロールは誰がどういうふうにするのかと
特にあの これ あのテレビショッピングではね
よく明確に分かりますね
派手に喋って喋って 顔を知られて
顔を知っている あの有名な人々を何人か
でもしかし 売れてないというね
そういう人々が まあ日本国民みんな知ってるんですけど
あまり売れないというね
人々がそちらに集めて
まあ驚くわ 演じるわ まあどうすっげえ下手な演じでね
だから売れないでしょうね
しっかり演じできればね
映画とかなんとかに雇われますしね
で それやって それからそれなりにお金払って
この視聴者も何人かをね
集めてもらおう みんなにちゃんとお金くれるんだから
信号出すときは笑う 信号出すときは拍手する
信号出すときはとか歓声上げたりするというね
全部一応用意しているんです
まあだからこのフロアマネージャーという人がちゃんとそれは看板出すんです
で これで品物を見せたら
で あの それはいいんだけど
値段ですねとまた言うんですね
やっぱり高いでしょうとかね
言ったら商売やってる人は
ああ そうなんですけど
じゃあ今回に限って  2万円に切るんだと
だからまあ  1万950円にしますと
あら  2万円切ってる ものすごく驚いてくれますよ
あの周りの二人は そこで見ている私はね
あのね これはどこに買いたっても
これはまあ 3,000円だったらね
手ごろな値段だよと それでも俺にはいらんんだけど
どうしても必要な人は 3,000円ぐらい人に払ってもいいやと
私はそこでもう逆を考えているんです
次にみんな驚いて それならもう友達にも紹介しなくちゃ
あれやこれやと大騒ぎ終わったところで
あ 今回はそこで 2つ付けてあげますとかね 2
つ付いたところで またもうどこまでびっくりするのか
もうもうできないところまで 2
つではなくて じゃあ一応もう一つ
まあいいやということで 3つ出すんです
それで私はあのね  1個で十分なのに 3個はいりませんと
3個は 2万950円で買っても値段高すぎやと
で 自分がもうかかってないんです
しかし かかるでしょう
だからあんなもうダサい
もうもう演じするんですかね
だってお金かかるでしょうね
テレビコマーシャルにしたっても
テレビショッピングにも
だからもう別に通販で買うのは構いませんよ
買う場合はマインドコントロールされないで
自分の判断で この品物なら私に必要だよと
あ これが手ごろな値段だよと
あなた言ったんではなくて
自分の意思で買うんだぞという気持ちで買わなくちゃいけないんですよ
しかし 買わされるでしょ？だから見事にマインドコントロールされているんですよ
そこで私たちはそういう巧みな言葉に酔ってしまうという
もう他見えなくなるんですよ
これは先天的な集中力なんです
もし自分が好みの自分を知っているとか
もう自分がよく見慣れているタレントさんだったら
もうコマーシャルのところじゃなくて
こういう人々に興味行ったりするんですね
だから そういう人々の仕草やら喋ることやら
それは面白くて見ているんです
普段ひどい喜ばす人間でしょうに
それでついでにこれむちゃくちゃ買わされているということになっちゃうんですね
だから我々は このものすごく仮物にされているというか
悪用されているんです
この世の中で だから私はかなりこのあらゆるコマーシャル
いろんなものをよくよくものすごく厳しく見て分析するんです
で だからそのその国の国民性がちゃんとコマーシャルに表れるんです
コマーシャルならなんで国民性が表れるんですかね
あれはマインドコントロールだからなんです
その国の国民の気持ちに合わせないと買わないというね
例えば日本のコマーシャルでは買いなさいということを言わないんですね
すごいことや もう世紀末というか
まあ今世紀の大発明だ
あれやこれやとかね たった日本だけ世界で初めて開発したんだとかね
嘘も嘘ですけど 調べてみると
もうかなり前からイギリス
アメリカにあったものなんですけど
で そういう風にガチャガチャ言うだけで
で 通販でしか手に入りません
店では全然もう買えないんだよとだけ言うんです
そう言われると買う気になるでしょ
日本人はそう言われると買う気になるんです
で アメリカだったら今注文しなかったらあなた損しますよと言うんですね
今注文しなかったら もうあなたはアウトだよと
だから買いなさいと言うんです
向こうは競争社会で もう先に取った人は勝ちということだから
それで対照する他の品物があったら
それは馬鹿にするんですね
勝手に 日本ではそれはしません
だから日本の方々は日本のコマーシャルのほうが一番かっこいいと思っている
で インドのテレビのコマーシャルはえらい気持ち悪いと思ってますけど
インド人はあれがすごいかっこいいと思っているんです
で 私にとっては世界中コマーシャル何でも気持ち悪いんです
だからじーっとそういうものを見るんです
見て気持ち悪くなったりして
で 分析してみたりはします
そういうことで 私たちは先天的に持っている集中力は
まあそれぞれ人間みんな平等じゃないんだから
国によってそれぞれ違うし
年によってもその先天的集中力は変わるし
男性女性によってもそれはそれぞれ変わってしまうしね
だからまあそれに合わせて我々はかなり悪用されているということがあります
あのオレオレ詐欺事件というのはね
日本以外できませんだからね
だからいかに自分だけの世界に閉じ込められているのかという
自分の孫の声がわからないというならばおかしいんです
普通だったらね 口先で何言ったっても
家族っていうのはもう気持ちわかるんですね
気持ちが通じるんですよ
例えばもう子供は大丈夫ですよ
何の問題もないんだよとお母さんに電話したっても
お母さんすぐわかる なんか大変みたいなとかね
なんか大変みたいな すぐわかるんです
だから私ども時々いろいろたまたま誰か電話して
突然随分時間経って久しぶりに電話すると
あ どうですか？元気です
あのね あんた何かやっちゃったでしょうね
突然何のことなく聞くんです
何かやっちゃったでしょうねとか
知ってます あの波動で何かトラブっちゃって
そこを頭混乱しちゃって
それは何とかしてほしいってことだからね
で そこは読み取らないと
喋っても喋ってもただのご挨拶で終わっちゃうんです
ああ そうですか 今何やってるんですか？あれやこれやとか面白くないんですよ
それでは役にも立たないし
それはいきなりはっきり言いなさいよと
あんた何やったのかと
そう言われると あ バレたのかという感じで
もう何のことなく言うし
それにこちらアドバイスして
それで気分良く終わっちゃうし
うまくいったらまた電話かけてこないの
半年とかね いうことなんで
だからこのそれも先天的な集中力で私もやってますけど
だからこの自分だけの世界に閉じ込められて
孫の面倒を見るべきだとか
孫が心配すると とにかく何かやってあげなくちゃっていう妄想だけがあって
だからどんな男が電話したってもうまくいくんです
だからちょっと聞いてみれば
ヘリコプターすぐわかるでしょうに
今お金銀行に入れなきゃ大変
ありえないでしょうに
孫やら息子やら だいたい親のことを家族の知ってるんだから
言い方があるはずなんです
その家族独特の 独特の
親と子以外あまりにも知らない
いろいろ仕草やらね 弟とかね
あるんです だからこのコマーシャル世界で生きてるんだから
まあそちらにマインドコントロールされちゃって
また他の先天的な能力が機能しなくなっちゃっているんです
だから先天的集中力は悪くないんだけど
それをちゃんと生かしてほしいし
それを生かせば我々幸福で生きていられるし
この弱みがあるんだから
そこは弄られて まあいろんな危険なことになるんです
人は自分のために 他人の他人を支配管理しようとするんですね
人に管理されていいわけじゃないんです
人は自分のために相手を管理しようとしてるんです
宗教の場合も同じなんです
とにかく管理しようとしてるんですね
信者さんを だからものすごい独裁的なんですね
宗教の世界は 上はもう絶対的上で
神は絶対的神でこんにちはとは言うんじゃないんですね
だからなんとか宗教組織に入ったら
自分がいつでも身分が低くて
そこでいなくちゃいけないんですね
どういうことを管理するのかというと
日本の場合はね 時々我は神様やと言っている人がもうくたびれて死ぬでしょう
死ぬ時 今までふざけて贅沢三昧で生きていた息子か娘が改装というか
次のなることが 何よこれと
宗教的精神的な世界だったら
もう初めの詐欺師が死んだら
次にもうその辺の訓練した詐欺師が行くことでしょうね
麻原の組織の場合でも
娘か誰かが次の最終解脱者になるようにもう設定してあったんです
日本の新興宗教 みんなそうでしょ
次に子供に行くんですね
何よこれと 例えば政治
政治と言いながら 北朝鮮で父が死んだら息子がもう永久的絶対的権力握ってる
もう何様でしたっけ？将軍様ですね
それで学校の子供たち目で毎朝毎晩拝まなくちゃいけない
どんな政治ですかね それで厳密に管理しているでしょう
マインドコントロール
厳密に思考の自由も動きの自由も何でもなくしたって
それで気分がいいと思いますかね
だからこの我々には弱みが当然あるんですよ
結局は この先天的に だから気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
完全たる慈しみで見返りは断然断る人はいるのでしょうかと
世の中で で なんで神を賛嘆しなくちゃいけないのかというと
脅されてるんですね でなきゃ永遠な地獄に落ちるんだよと
で 逆になんで神がそんなにも褒めてほしいのかと
おかしいでしょうに 全知全能なのに
人間どもが褒めなきゃいけない
どういうことですかね
だからこの 誰かが 詐欺師が
詐欺師たちが 自分が収入を得るために人々を馬鹿にして独裁気分になるために作る話ですよ
だから弱い人間がすぐ乗るんです
だから もし完全たる慈しみの人
人のことはもう完全に慈しむ
見返りなんか微塵も期待しない
もう断る それぐらいの人が管理したっても構いませんよ
何も自分が損を受けません
自分がダメになるとすぐ助けてくれるんです
はい その程度 例えば微妙にこの母と子の関係ではあるんですね
どんな人間でも やっぱり母が何か言うともう
なんか変になってしまうんですね
断れようとも断ることもできないし
すごい複雑な状況になるんです
すごい凶暴な人でも もう喧嘩しに行く
人を殺しに行くって みんな怖くて
だってもうボロボロとしてるお母さんが名前でお前こっちおいでと言ったら
何のこともなく来るんです
いい加減にしなさいというと
ああ しょうがないということになるんですね
それもコントロールされてますよ
母という存在に それが決して悪くはないんです
母にマインドコントロールされていることは
なぜならば 母は自分の子供には不幸
子供が不幸になってほしいとはもうほとんど思わないんですね
全然ほとんど思わないし
思えないし ですから まあ母以外
父以外はね 気をつけた方がいいんです
しかし 我々の母父っていうのは完全じゃないんでしょうね
それには それの人々にも自分の欲やらいろいろあるでしょうね
自分の見方というものもあるし
それは一つも完全じゃないんです
だから危ないのは危ないんだけど
でもやっぱり自分のことを心配しているんだから
まあそんなに悪いことにはならなかった
今までは 小学者である釈尊さえ人をマインドコントロール管理しようとしなかったんです
だから仏教の場合は お釈迦様というのは完全たる人格者で
完全たる慈しみがあって
もう悟りに達しているんだから
何一つもいらないんです
もう人生はもう完了しているんです
輪廻脱出しているんです
何もいらん しかし 人のことは心配する
それだけ心配して人々は修行したんだから
お釈迦様には何の得もないんです
だからまあ余計な迷惑や余計な迷惑やと思いつつ説法していたんです
できればやめたいんだと
ややこしいんだと で そこまでのお釈迦様なのに
人を管理しようと一回もやってないんです
ものすごく逆を言うんです
はっけい 私は教えるだけだよと
これがもう世界一上手だよと
教えるのは しかし 頑張るのは君たちであると
自分の力で幸福になりなさいよと
やり方は教えてあげる
それで話は終わりやと
それで いかにこの人を管理するために仏教が現れてないっていうことは
あるエピソードを作ってあるんです
お釈迦様が見た夢だと悟る前に
これをおそらく作った話かもしれません
で あるいはお釈迦様が実際にそういう夢を見たかもしれません
で すごいクソの山があって
釈尊がそのクソの山を歩いているんですね
クソの汚いクソの山だから気持ちいいわけじゃないでしょ
もう触れたくもないんだけど
どうしようもない 夢の中だからね
クソの上を歩かなくちゃいけない
その夢の解説は 釈尊がブッダになって悟ってからは
世間はあらゆるものは寄付するんだと
お布施するんだと 人々のお布施でもう溢れてしまいますよ
しかし ブッダにとってはそれはクソだと
ああ よかったよかった
立派なお寺ができて まあギリシア風の本堂ができたとかね
日本人の宗教なんですけど
本山の建物の設計はギリシア神話風というあるんだからね
見て見てください 場所は控えます
もう一つ見た夢で お釈迦様の膝までウジ虫がいっぱいついて
これも夢なんです このウジ虫
なおさら気持ち悪くて
頭が黒くて体が白くて
もう膝まできゅうきゅうとウジ虫がついていて
これ夢で結構気持ち悪くなったでしょう
それでその夢の解説は
釈尊が悟ってから説法すると
大勢の人々が仏教を聞くことになるんだと
仏教を信じて実践する人々になるんだと
その最期の人々をウジ虫なんです
だから信者さん獲得してよかったよかったと威張ると思いますかね
だからその裏で何が読めるのかという
いかに仏教は人を管理しようとしないということなんです
マインドコントロールしようとしないことなんです
ブッダの威力にやられてもうどうしようもないってことじゃないんです
もしお釈迦様に言われたら
そんなこと あなたの威力でね
私はもう何もわからなくなって
あなたの信者さんになったんだよと
お釈迦様からウジ虫やとあんたはと
いう話なんです だからたくさんのエピソードあるんです
お釈迦様は私に超能力を教えてくれるならば
真面目に修行するんだそうと
お釈迦様 あんたに出家しろ私は言ったの？と
すぐ反論するんです 君
出家しなさい 私は超能力を育てる方法を教えてあげるそうと
私はそういうふうに商売したんですかと
というか 言う 何といいますか
あなたに勧めたんですかと
いい お釈迦様は出家しなさい
勧めてないんだよと だったら何言うのと
あんたはと それでこの前質問したんですね
どなたか 私は何か言ったポイントということは
出家することではないかと言った途端
私の頭に別のアイデアが浮かんだんです
45年間説法をなされたお釈迦様は
一回だけでも人に君出家しなさいと言ってないんです
一回だけでも 言ってないんです
すごいでしょう しかし
どれほどの人を出家したのかと
それでも一回一つだけ
お釈迦様は自分の息子がもう初めて見て
息子がお釈迦父親に初めて会って
もう7歳ぐらいなんですね
息子は父親にもべったし
もう体につけてもう一緒に大人まで行くと
で ラーフラ子どもがまあ父親のものは私のものでしょうと
だからもう私に財産くれと
たらに言ったら もうサーリプッタ尊者ね
この子はね 私の財産欲しがっているんだと
だから私の財産 この子にも入るようにちょっと何とかしてあげてくださいと言って出家されたんです
で 当然あの後 それからまあ小さい頃はね
まあ普通大きくなりましたけど
年頃になってくるとちゃんと瞑想も教えてあげて
瞑想して悟りに達しましたけど
悟りに達する時はまあ大人になってましたけど
それでお釈迦様の財産は自分のものになっちゃったんです
そのケースだけですね
お釈迦様 人に聞かないで人を出家されたのは
しかし それ父親だからね
誰にも文句言えないんですよ
父親は自分の子供 どんな学校に行ってたって
誰が文句言うんですかね
権利ないでしょ それでもお釈迦様には批判を受ける羽目になったんです
自分の父親から怒られたんです
あなたは父親の気持ちわからないのかと
あなた出家してから私はどれほど悲しかったか知らないのかと
それで 私がそうですね
孫まで出家させたりして
まだまだ子供でしょうにと
これからあなたはね こういうもう親に厳しい悲しい思いをさせないでくださいと
すると お釈迦様もやっぱりいくらお釈迦様であっても
父親の話は聞く わかりましたと
それで禁止したんですね
親の許可なき出家は禁止だと
しかし お釈迦様は一人にもあなた出家しなさいと言ってないんです
それでお釈迦様は真理を教えてあげて
どのように解脱に達するのかと教えてあげたところで
相手がこれをやろうとしなければ
真面目にやるならば出家でもしなきゃ無理だなとか
本人が思うんであって
だからすごく気をつけていますよ
マインドコントロールにならないようにと
だから今もその伝承で私たちがお願いしなくちゃいけないんです
何々してくださいと お願いしますと
入れてくださいと 入れてくださいと
こちらが頼んだならば
向こうの規則を一方的に守らなくちゃいけない
向こうはこういうこういう決まりを守るならばOKするんだよと
だから一旦出家してもわがままは通じない
私はこれが好き これがやりたくないと言うとも
まあ出て行けと 関係ないんだと
ということになるんです
しかし 出家された出家した人々は一人もマインドコントロールされているんだという気持ちは微塵もない
あの神父さんみたいにすごく怯えたり
恐怖感を感じたり 自己嫌悪に陥ったり
まるっきりない いつでも自分の意思で
自分の気持ちで 自分がやりたいんだからやっているんだということなんです
はい そこを言ったのは
このお釈迦様さえ人をマインドコントロールしてないんです
なのに この世の中どうでしょうかね
自分を褒め称えて欲しくて
一生懸命我々のこの先天的な集中力という弱みを握られているんです